the motivation was the top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something greater
inside you as well you've got Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to master communication stop
caring what other people think and play
to win with Dane Pena and my take on his
top ten roses excess volume nine to give
you the confidence motivation and belief
that you need joy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one master
communications you you if you can't fail
your dream nobody's gonna join you Oprah
Winfrey's got a saying about you know
it's it's not exactly important where
the bus is going but the people that you
have on the bus with you because you're
gonna morph you're going to pivot which
is true and if you are not enthusiastic
overwhelmingly enthusiastic that's not
been one of my shortcomings
I've always been enthusiastic and and
I've had good good to great
communication skills and the but you
don't have if you if your communication
skills are 5% of mine they have no
problem being a billionaire 5% of mine
5% and that's why I tell you go to
improv go to Toastmasters etc I got a F
in public speaking in high school I got
an F in public speaking in university
and I got a D in public speaking the
second time University but then I went
to made to 250 speeches where I told you
and then some of you don't believe me
they threw plates at me they threw
dinner rolls at me but I didn't leave
the podium
I emptied out auditoriums my speaking
skills were so poor rule number two
don't care what others think like the
world has become sophisticated political
correctness range and I'm humble opinion
is not about me that political
correctness is the manifestation of lack
of self esteem did you care about what
people say about me you care about what
people think about you and I got and
either this Jeff Bebo's Bill Gates
Warren Buffett Elon Musk Henry Ford the
first and I go down with rule number
three play to win I want to open
hundreds of salons around the United
States even in Europe my problem is how
do I find a team I can trust how do I
find a good team and that's what I'm
having you don't find a team by not
taking action you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes that's just the way it is the
more you question it the less you're
going to be inclined to pull the trigger
I would rather make a mistake then just
think about making a mistake
so you're so afraid you're you so used
to playing not to win and play not to
lose rule number four always keep
practicing just like the astronauts the
astronauts trained for years and years
and years before they go up for every
contingency for every single possibility
and some of the possibilities are one in
a trillion but they still train for him
practice practice practice the people
that are doing the most and dr. Joshi
alluded to it himself he practices it's
very easy to get sloppy after you've
done a bunch of jokes I practice between
1 & 1 & a half hours for this seminar
for every app before the seminar
I had in about 7080 hours in the
seminars fifty hours long 78 75 80 hours
that I practice and I know what's on
slide 11 58
and then you know sometimes I skip 2030
sighs and I I did skip because we had
already gone over this stuff last night
when I was working and the because we're
going to talk about goals now and and if
you don't see your vision
Bill Gates I'm told although I never
asked him he saw a computer in every
house okay and I told you yesterday he
now was yours he said he put two
computers in every house and most houses
do have to write some have three four
five and then he said I should have said
a computer every I said on the entire
planet but they all practice there's a
slide coming up and showing Hitler
practice practicing when he was
practicing before he became Chancellor
in 1933 I think it was maybe 32 I he had
over a million pictures taken of him a
minion in the right pose the right
there's the right hand gesture yes to
the right so he could be more effective
he studied great speakers before him and
arguably uh mr. Hitler even though he
was an ass all he was learned when the
great orator of all time also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my 254 series they're free the links to
Joyner in the description below you want
people with a like mind and it that are
better than you smarter than you more
intelligent than you to get on your bus
but knowing guys know initially upfront
you have to try if the swing at the
plate a kid like you if you had to keep
track of seven days a week 24 hours a
day what you do rule number five use
storytelling I think people realize that
how great you are the communicator and
I'm always very like shocked to how good
you are even as a storyteller how great
your memory is there you'll be the tell
story how do you do that well I work at
it when I first started I didn't have
any stories yes I only had the stories
of my mentors yeah okay
and some do man yeah Jim Newman Kosta
carrasco's who was CEO vanassa's
shipping
and a guy named Jerry Ormond who is my
mentor in the oil business and so but
over time I learned by storing around
meaning people will allow information to
resonate into their subconscious when
they hear it in a story form and so when
I saw that my mentors used stories and
they were pulling stuff from 20 30 years
ago that resonated with me and so then I
developed my storytelling abilities and
I and I tried to frame everything I did
in a story and a true story and now the
the occasionally I'll miss a date and
somebody from the internet will correct
me no it wasn't in 2001 it was 2002
that's fine at least I have a backstop
but I'm only off a year and I've got a
million stories so give me a break you
do yeah but I realize how how much they
work and now I have stories that I can
tell about you yes I have stories I can
tell about you know Brian Rose I have
stories about many many other successful
kids and and and that resonates even
more with the kids rule number six be
willing to break some eggs as soon as we
got tougher as soon as we got less PC as
soon as we got that we didn't care what
they said or thought about us we got
more successful and we started doing
deals
we started doing deals you cannot do you
know a lot of transactions without
hurting feelings you know the old saying
about to make an omelet you gotta break
eggs you know and everybody that's ever
had an omelet there's normally some kind
of eggshell in it because they can't get
all the eggshell out collateral damage
Fred Smith the founder of Federal
Express said he's similar background
similar age he was a young marina
officer I was using robbery officer he
said when he came back from Vietnam as
soon as he realized his mistakes
the collateral damage of his mistakes
did not end up with body bags
meaning dead people he says the rest was
easy so the worst I was ever going to do
is hurt somebody's feelings make him cry
and he built Federal Express and he's
one of the icons of business who's still
running them business rule number seven
be tough in theory we should be able to
kill off the Russians easy but we won't
kill up the resident because they're
tough they're tough now when I went
through Ranger School
they hung us from trees and put battery
wires on artistical 's
there are dozens and hundreds of
lawsuits against the federal government
because the guys couldn't have kids they
take us out on anthills and pour honey
over us and let the ants eat is for two
or three days this was a training
and now and you're right I mean when the
spirit of the beignet used to be to kill
and you're going through a boot camp you
know many a broken tooth cracked jaw
because your drill sergeant hit you in
the face with the butt of the rifle and
no you wonder why we're all concerned
that's why I bring my own security I'll
get I happen I'm not ignoring you in a
Toronto if somebody finally asked me why
did you bring the cricket bat snowflake
I said because they your school told me
I should have security which they did
I'm not gonna pay a bunch of goons no I
can do the same as they can't and I said
and what and then there's somebody asked
me about 20 minutes what do you do with
a cricket bat I swore to you and then I
jump down off the stage and I said
because the first five or six if you
aren't going to come at me even though
that's 400 of you because you don't want
to be the first one two or three that I
knocked their head off but they had to
ask me what I was gonna do with a
cricket bat that's a lot that's where we
are
rule number eight don't give in
programming you're yourself and your
habits really isn't that difficult when
you understand what makes the synapses
fire it's not it's not that hard but
you're not used to saying no you're used
to saying yes or not saying anything and
giving tacit approval how many times for
those of you who have a significant
other there's a significant other say
something you know just [ __ ] just
give in make peace why make more right I
don't fall into that category and if
you're used to saying yes just to not
make war or you're used to giving tacit
approval just not to make more at home
that follows you in the rest of your
life
I follow soon the rest your life and but
once you get used to it
like most spouses significant others
will say guys he's changed she's changed
most will say for the worse until you
get back from them do you get momentum
oh god I like the new rolls by night I
like to do this I like plan first class
now Dan's a genius now but that takes
some time at six and time rule number
nine model success success leaves clues
if you know all you know if successful
if the super successful people don't
hang chill chill don't go to Super Bowls
and all those things and the hard-asses
okay but only 90 percent of the high
performers in the world or alpha males
2% or alpha males 98 percent of regular
people
because for example Elon Musk Zuckerberg
Warren Buffett all share one attribute
they're introverts this out continually
correction yeah
and so I mean you don't have to be an
alpha male and back in the day a hundred
years ago and doing research for one of
my talks they had obviously alpha males
but they didn't call them alpha males
they call them oak trees oak tree oak
trees because that was considered the
straightest thing in the forest and it
didn't break down and so they were
called oak trees and the but when I tell
people about Zuckerberg Elon Musk Warren
Buffett all being introverts because
most people are introverts most people
are pleasers and rule number ten the
last one before very special bonus clip
is find your drive what drive you did
well when I went into coaching twenty
five and a half years ago I wanted to
change what was called personal
development then and the true financial
coaching stroke mentoring and I didn't
know what I would
to do to do it but whatever I've done in
my life I always want to lead I want to
be first so after about four or five
years I discovered that I even though
I'm a good motivating motivational
speaker that's not what I want to do I
want to teach how to create generational
wealth okay well if that normally takes
twenty to twenty-five years to create
which is the definition of a generation
in three to seven years as we were
saying in the car on the way over here
three years if you do everything
perfectly which we know nobody does it
perfectly go six or seven years for
somebody that's good and eight to ten
years if you're a real doofus and I
realized the work that it would take and
that I sold all my portfolio I sold all
my assets Sally and I have been in cash
for a long long time because I don't
want there to be a conflict between me
giving the kid advice and my own
personal investment strategy and so the
as we've continued develop the templates
the processes the systems and the
procedures they're based on success one
success after another success last four
or five years we've produced teenage
multi millionaires some of the teenage
multi millionaires as you can witness on
YouTube are flying around their own
goddamn jet planes now we we've produced
the largest deal in recorded history the
five hundred billion dollar Neum which
is the ascent city of the 22nd or 23rd
century with a man T Klaus Kleinfeld so
we've got everything from millions tens
of millions hundreds of millions
billions tens of billions and even
hundreds of billions now and we have all
the systems how to do it and 99.9% of
all the kids that have benefited from
the qlae I've never met I would know him
if they were standing in this room
because we decided almost ten years ago
to give all the product away free
because I went as you pointed I went to
the most expensive products online yeah
feel free yes because that takes away
almost all the excuses of the kids that
are just flapping their mouths now I
have a special bonus gift from Dan that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where
does your drive come from
number two who are three people who
success you can model this week and
number three where do you just need to
be tough and not give in and if you
liked this video and you're gonna take
some action after watching it give me a
hash tag believe down in the comments as
well I think he may be here and I don't
know I don't want to embarrass anyone
but is the guy they got kicked out of
the last seminar is he in the room no
okay never mind
oh he's from Brazil okay then I want to
watch punch somebody else in the okay oh
good point yes sir he's knocks at our
door 1:30 in the morning right screaming
and yelling I get up out of bed Sally
gets up out of bed and I'm gonna throw
him off the balcony my babe for those
about we live on the second floor and
the balcony and yeah and and Sally need
need us to say I'm not putting words in
her mouth she's sitting right here that
we don't need that and so Sally walked
him down the staircase and out the door
he's being a psycho what I did know is
he went into two or three other rooms to
harass people one of much a good-looking
doctor a lady doctor 600 men were in
that within earshot him with between
where you are sitting Jason Tom you
could bedrooms on the same floor
not one single man except one came out
to see somebody getting raped killed or
murdered one guy who came out to take
pictures the little try to kill
[Music]
this is a little skinny about your size
we had three big black dudes brothers
not a one it's got any testicles the
next day when the police struck him off
as you see on the Internet
he said he was going to cut the eyes out
of the black brothers and eat him okay
he said I'm waiting for you at the
airport [ __ ] I'm gonna kill you all
now we got 19 people in that seminar
room three big black dudes they were
changing their airline ticket so they
didn't have to fly out of Edinburgh as
God is my witness this little [ __ ] I
could snap his neck like a pencil that's
why I said when I say you got no balls
anymore you got no balls anymore
my wife drags the guy down the staircase
and you're all there huddled someplace
putting furniture against the door when
I say you're through as a race I mean
you're [ __ ] through
if you want more dan pain yeah I checked
at the top fifty rules video I made on
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
Adolf Hitler might be the highest
performance guy that ever was born on
the planet when you decide that you
really want to invoke permanent change